so listen we need to know what's going
on with Donald Trump's health in this
story I'm talking about physical health
not mental health mental health of
course has also been a big topic of
concern but that's not the focus for
today
last weekend Donald Trump went to Walter
Reed Hospital for an unplanned visit the
White House has since said oh he was
getting a jump start on his 20/20
physical this is not something a
president has ever done this is
something that dr. Sanjay Gupta
indicates is not how physicals are done
as a general rule it was all very weird
Walter Reed said they weren't expecting
Trump Trump was out of sight for two
days following the visit then when he
finally got back in front of the cameras
he looked acutely not good so the other
day I noticed Donald Trump arriving on
Air Force One in Austin Texas and I
noticed a couple of unusual things
Donald Trump other than looking very
sort of ginger as he exited gingerly
walking I should say not ginger as he
exited the plane left through a lower
door on Air Force One not something that
presidents tend to do uh but he was also
followed closely behind by White House
doctor Shawn Connelly who then got into
Donald Trump's limo with him now it is
normal for the White House doctor to
travel with the president it is not
normal for the White House doctor to
come off the plane right behind the
president and then ride in the
president's limo with them a former
White House doctor actually said to CNN
that when they were a doctor
they never rode with the president the
entire time that they were working there
and indeed when Donald Trump rode back
from the hospital last week the doctor
also rode with Trump which is very odd
we've now heard from Walter Reed staff
that normally when the president goes
there certain roads are closed certain
corridors in the hospital are closed
didn't happen last weekend because they
didn't know Trump was going so dr.
Sanjay Gupta has been looking at all of
this he says look you've got a 73 year
old Trump who has heart disease he's
medicated for it he's clinically obese
he admits that he doesn't work out he
has a long history about lying regarding
his health and still now nine days after
this Walter Reed Hospital visit nothing
is adding up and on top of it
Trump is now riding
with his doctor in the limo after coming
off of the planes lower stairs which is
unusual and again speculating
speculators might be thinking that the
idea is have Trump come off of lower
stairs in the event he were to fall he
can take smaller stairs so for me there
is a very simple explanation here
they're lying to us we don't know
exactly why we need to know the truth
they're lying to us we're not looking to
make fun of anyone for being obese or
being sick or anything like that this is
about the lying needs to stop it was a
lie when Harald Bornstein put together
that bogus letter saying Trump would be
the healthiest president ever to be
President Trump obviously wouldn't even
be healthier than the prior President
Barack Obama never mind every president
irresponsible thing for Harald Bornstein
to say they were lying when they said
Trump was I believe 6-3 to 39 which
would put him just one pound short of
being obese Trump is closer to 6 feet
tall 511 6 feet 6 feet and a half
something like that based on being
shorter than Obama being shorter than
Tom Brady it's lie after lie after dot
after lie we just need to know the truth
that's all and if you really want to see
another indicator that something is
wrong with Trump's health he has not
gone this long without golfing his
entire presidency we'll have more
information about that I don't I don't
want to muddle that in but but it's it's
a related story and we will talk about
that tomorrow something is wrong here we
are not being told the truth and I think
we deserve to be told the truth